you've got kind of a uh frame question
um so just drop your question out for
everybody say right
so basically long story short uh
lost a fight girl i was kind of you know
interested in she lost all respect for
me
i don't really need to i can kind of
guess put two and two together what you
know what that kind of comes in
uh but how do you lose a fight i don't
understand how that
happens oh uh long story short there was
a
off-campus uh you know
invite uh bonfire theme was
you know fight night because of the jake
paul thing i think and
um oh you mean you actually lost a
physical fight with somebody else
yeah but it was kind of a uh like
a playful fight it was like us friends
too pitted each man is given one boxing
glove to like kind of water it down it
was
but uh other fights got more heated um
so she's like that clip on the joe rogan
experience that i shared on
tick tock where that chick dumped her
boyfriend because he lost the uh mma
fight
yeah you were dancing around the issue
it was exactly like that issue arguably
i lost
well now you see yes but anyway
um women don't care about your struggles
they hang out the finish line right
right and i i completely understand that
so i don't need to
really understand that but basically it
kind of led to the next question which
is
and i mentioned the last show with you
rich and paul was frame was something
that i'm really trying to work on and i
struggle with
and when you can't really uh like in
your ex
example rich when you just you know
pulled that wheel said get the [ __ ] out
it's very
me included it's like i admit i would
hesitate to do something like that
because i've been conditioned to
you know like i said my question almost
fear a woman's rather like the
repercussions of that and it's i guess
the big question is when it comes to
frame is
how do you overcome fear of women you
know
what are you afraid of i can i can feel
this one if you want well at the time i
was listening to a lot of snoop dogg in
nwa and it just like was in me man i was
listening to it
ryan that's right did you have like a
strong
dad growing up uh
short answer i'm gonna guess most of
your teachers are probably chicks too
not a lot of male teachers you have no
idea older sister mom homeschooled k
through
12 by my mom yeah catholic by the way
really your religion book is
oh you like just started it it's
probably going to be my favorite because
of that background for me
thank you but here if this makes you
feel better this is surprisingly common
oh this is i know it is yeah this is
literally and this is why
you're having such a problem with it
it's literally because of mental models
mental models
are just the human brain thinks in
narratives we think in stories and
the ones you were raised with which are
usually involved they call them
failed parenting strategies dr glover
talks a lot about this no more mr nice
guy
the idea is usually without strong
father figures mothers because they
don't have physical strength to
discipline kids
they tend to play an identity if you're
a bad boy this you know a good son would
do this
you're pissing me off and she like it's
almost like threatening abandonment now
as a kid
you don't have a developed frontal lobe
so what you do is you treat that
rejection
as a fight-or-flight fear which makes
sense
back in the days when our brains were
developing if we if mom left us in the
woods we were going to get eaten
so you're treating this as a
fight-or-flight response so naturally as
a as a good boy
you do what your mother tells you to you
clean your room you [ __ ] like that
and this is all limbic brain [ __ ] so
female validation is one of those things
that's reinforced now the problem comes
is
by four or five years old i believe it
is these things are kind of hard wired
as instinctive in our heads
what you need in these points are guys
that offer more stability
saying yeah we could be mad at each
other but as long as you do x y and z
you'll be fine it's a certain level of
comfort
that children need to be raised around
women aren't very good at it but men are
so you have this model that you've built
up since you were five years old
which you know whatever you join the
military you get boarding school you
join
elementary school male teachers would
kind of help getting out of your system
too but that's the problem with female
teachers
and in your case the homeschooling it
just reinforces the same thing that you
knew as a limbic response since you were
five
some guys don't make it to like 18 19
years old till they have a single male
authority figure which they've never had
before
the reason that you have a hard time
with that rejection is not because you
can't think through the problem we can
all tell you exactly what just say this
and you'll be fine
and your frontal lobe agrees yeah just
say this you'll be fine but your limbic
brain
is still thinking like that
five-year-old kid that's had 15 years
of reinforcement to say if you piss the
woman off you're gonna die
that's why if we were to ask you right
now why is it you can't do this
you couldn't articulate why you just
don't feel comfortable doing it
i think that's fair enough the way i
described there yes very in fact when
you say identity and my mom
i'm no longer you know religious enough
because it
for multiple reasons and i'm spinning
plates i'm doing things you know that
i'm you know been learning for the past
two years and my mom is very uh
handling for handling it fairly well but
not happy about it to say the least
so exactly and those girls the ones
you're dating now
all it takes is one bpd chick who's got
a control issue
and that'll rumble that house of cards
this is how those i used to be alpha but
slowly became beta guys this is how it
happens
now as for your answer how do you fix it
it's
really slowly it's like the guy who's
learning how to walk after he had his
spine reattached
you have to practice and you have to
practice very small examples
like you can't just start 10 out of 10
kick your wife out of the house get out
of my car
i'm going to the grocery store you start
with the smallest
most insignificant boundary you can
think of and it's going to feel
uncomfortable
but because it's such a small boundary
you're going to be able to enforce it
and you're going to have to do that like
a hundred times
remember it's took you 20 some years to
get here you're not going to lose it all
overnight
but then you're practicing a combination
of desensitization
and i don't know the exact term for it
but it's
i've talked about kiloology i don't want
to ramble about it here but habituation
maybe
yeah that's what i talked about but it's
the same reason that when paul goes to
shoot at silhouettes in the trial
on the target range he doesn't worry on
the battlefield about shooting a person
because to him it's just the silhouette
he's got that brain pathway
and he's repeated it enough it can weak
works perfectly and you'd essentially
more annoyed when it's a silhouette
oh exactly if there's one more thing
that i can say before i
head out is um because if i if i'm
confronted with a girl and she starts
disrespecting me i have no frame of
reference and i know one easy way to say
you know get
better male friends which i am working
on and have
but uh basically i have no frame of
reference of like what to say
what do you do when a girl disrespect or
anyone
for that matter and my friends my two
friends who i have
um they basically uh their biggest thing
is about like i can't stand when someone
disrespects me and i know the difference
is they have uh an ability to be angry
if something that's very unique to me
that i've noticed with any male friend
i've ever had or any other guy
is i have no anger issues
let me throw something out here listen
man all right so if you're going to
do public speaking right and you were
kind of nervous about public speaking or
whatever what would you do
you practice in front of a mirror right
you would figure out what you're going
to say
and maybe practice in front of a small
audience and you go out there and do it
that's what we call rehearsals so a lot
of times what i'm doing like with guys
like my consultations and stuff when
we're doing like
mental conditioning is you go through
rehearsals you know
and so you can rehearse what your
response would be
you're not a dumb person you're a smart
guy so you know what
confronting disrespect would look like
we got enough content out here you know
to tell you
like hey man like this is this is how
you would handle this [ __ ] test or this
is how you would handle this
and so you know logically like what to
do the problem is
everything that ryan said is correct
your limbic brain goes
you know in the moment and you don't
execute there's a saying
called we don't rise to our expectations
we fall to our level of training
this is true for military stuff and this
is due for self-defense having to go
kill somebody
this is also true for these little
things too like pickup you know the
reason why pickup artists will rehearse
lines and dumb stuff you don't need a
line to pick up a girl
right but they rehearse that because
they're rehearsing
what to do so when their limbic brain
goes
you know they fall to their level of
training which
is the thing they rehearsed so start
rehearsing
what it would look like to set these
boundaries in these circumstances
and then then you'll just cause yourself
to do it
using ryan's steps that he mentioned
which is smaller things first and then
build up to bigger things
so hopefully that helps you out man
alternatively listen to some old school
like hardcore
like rap man like early snoop dogg some
nwa
[Music]
go and listen to suicidal tendencies you
can't bring me down
there's a there's a little lyric in that
that you can repeat over and over again
when somebody disrespects you
you'll know what it is when you come
across it by who suicidal tendencies
you can't bring me down angel at the end
of this if you don't know what you do
want in a situation just focus on what
you don't want
because you're going to suck you don't
know what you want right now because
you've never had the ability to look at
it from a masculine lens
but you do know the stuff you don't like
so if you start with there you'll at
least be able to narrow it down to a
smaller list of things and you'll have a
much better idea of what you do want
with what's left
all right well thank you so much thank
you to each and every one of you on rule
zero
i literally i was listening to paul i
was listening to
you know sterling i was listening to ro
the other last night
fresh and fit all of you guys are doing
amazing work
and same you know set my life video on a
straighter path so thank you so much
you got it samuel thanks for hopping on
man we'll see you later
you